for game one john gray
in the middle of the baseball diamond
trent grisham advancing to home plate
3-1 and this is popped up
into short center field trevor story
calling everybody off and the rocky
shortstop makes the kit jake cronin
worth
that's a good decision by the way by
john gray trevor throws him out that
takes discipline it takes discipline and
understanding of where guys are
positioned two outs here in the top of
the first manny machado the 2-2
is a little flare into center field but
plenty of room for hampson he's got it
john gray needs a dozen pitches to take
care of san diego in the top of the
first and on the mound today for the
padres making his eighth start in the
padres uniform is you darby rymel tapia
to lead it off will
and the last of the first here's a
one-two again
and a swing and a miss
ran that one down and in on rhyme topia
so a good battle but a strong count
one away at the bottom of the first one
on one out bottom of the first
there goes hampton and this ball is
lined to center field and it stays up
and now hampson's got to get back
grisham's throw fortunately he's off
line and he gets away so now hansen will
head back the other way
and after all that garrett's at second
with two outs
it's a put out for grisham and he's
charged with a throwing air to get a man
into scoring position
that's going to be a tough error on
trent grisham charlie
squares it up lines it grisham quickly
on it makes a good strong throw just
offline as trevor story faces darvish
up the middle base hit hampton around
third the rockies will take a
one-nothing lead
the trevor story comes through darvish
had trevor story 02.
non-competitive slider away then tries
to throw a fastball the air comes back
to
four five and six in the second inning
against john gray this is tommy pham
did he go
get him yes he did and he went too far
down at first base
nestor sejah said strike three fan so
here's brian o'grady two-two old grady
swing and a miss
got him with a slider john gray's second
strikeout ends the top of the second
grisham popped out to story at short to
start the game
and the pitch from gray and got him
called strike three good pitch by john
gray and it's a one two three top of the
third bottom of the third inning at
coors field one and two to gray and a
swing and a miss went up the ladder on
him second strikeout for you darvish one
out here in the third rymel tapia
popped up foul ground
machado from third base will make the
catch
more room with which to work he wasn't
entirely sure as he gingerly made his
way over crowd number two in the fourth
rockies lead it one to nothing it's jake
cronin worth
swings and sends the ball to right
center field hampson over there that
ball tailing back to him and he reaches
up to make the play two down base is
empty the big right-hander fires to fam
and it's a called strike three and he
gets the one two three frame with
strikeout number five bottom of the
fourth one nothing rockies one out
that'll bring up trevor story
popped up foul ground down from first
his chronoworth over his carrottini and
cartini
makes the catch right in front of the
rockies dugout by the railing uh that's
not an easy play he's kind of on the run
and that ball coming back a little bit
makes a stab at it and catches it from
the second out
this is in play left field routine for
tommy fan you can't see it can't see it
not so routine
it'll be a fly ball double
i mean tommy came on like i got it and
then he was nowhere near it it looked
like he was
in the track of it and then stuck both
hands out and
had no idea and the ball landed fair
about
eight or ten feet behind him and rolled
into foul ground
still one-nothing rockies as we move
into inning number five one-two pitch
strike three called he had kim looking
for something else
and john gets
punch out number six brian o'grady
one-two pitch is pulled matt adams
grabbed it stepped on first throws to
second and marcano is able to get in
there
what a play by matt adams that ball
scorched matt coming off the bag reached
back and snow coned it and was able to
get the out at first
but his throw to second not quite in
time to get marcano carrottini is
intentionally walked two on two down and
i'm going to pinch it or it's going to
be noah he is hit on the elbow here the
bases are going to be loaded for trent
grisham see what grisham can do here
first pitch coming he bunts puts it up
the third baseline it'll be handled by
gray he's got no play and the game is
tied everybody's safe
two out bases loaded squeeze perfectly
placed by trent grisham what a beautiful
bunt
at the perfect time this is a clinic by
trent grisham
that is a clinic you cannot place that
baseball out front of home plate any
better in a new game tied one to one
emilio pagan
now they're two outs trejo is still at
first base
that's a base hit left center field
trejo headed towards third
and grisham appropriately will throw
behind so it's first and third with two
outs garrett hampson coming up to face
pagod
now the eighth pitch of the at-bat and
it's swung on and missed strike three
pumped a fastball right on past him
pagan who strands two men in scoring
position with one out here in the sixth
inning to capita marcano one for two day
today
and a ground ball sharply hit the second
bobbled there by trejo he's got no play
anywhere
that could have been a double play ball
but trejo can't handle it and both reach
padres have the bases loaded with
two outs here in the sixth in a one-one
game stevenson to lead the rockies
victor caratini
this one is driven in the air to right
field it's back and the slam diego
padres their traveling show is on the
road in denver grant slam the first of
the year for victor caratini and the
padres take a 5-1 lead fastball right
down the middle there's the big hit that
the pirates have been looking for padres
up 5-1 ryan mcmahon
[Music]
this ball is hit well left center field
and it's uh
and
trevor's around third he's gonna score
another double for mcmahon and it's five
to two
tommy almost takes a double ring
[Applause]
one more step right off the end of the
glove 5-2 san diego two on one out for
the rockies
elias diaz pinch hitting
and this is hit the center field it's
going to get a run hole
here comes mcmahon it's five to three
bases loaded
for rybell tapia the tying run at second
now go
one is grounded back to melanson his
throw to first is in time and the inning
he is over story puts the tying runs on
with one out for ryan mcmahon
on the ground to first base so the bag
goes cronenworth for out number two
they're loaded up for elias diaz
popped up
into shallow right
andreoli will not make the catch it's
nola
he makes the grab the second baseman
going out almost a collision
almost a base hit but it's the end of
the game instead